I wonder also sugar bear like I'm really
very pushy
mama June is speaking out about her
strained relationship with ex-boyfriend
sugar bear
she's now claiming he was abusive here
she is on the Wendy Williams Show on
Tuesday this is what happens yeah love
you Shannon what happened you stupid
[ __ ]
that is Janus he abusive very
emotionally and physically he was been
and um there was a lot there's a lot of
stuff that was hit for many many years
um and did honey boo boo did your girls
know about it oh yeah they they em he
knows in this episode y'all are gonna be
shocked I mean like I said I mean
there's been said I mean I can give you
pumpkins I was his fault then the thing
that was showing here comes honey boo
boo we never did the car wreck um so
upset several things that happen on here
gonna be with it was kind of like
covered up sugar please for once be
honest oh yeah I'm not finna get on your
right now little mama June says viewers
will finally see the truth about sugar
bear in the upcoming reunion episode of
her we TV show from not too hot this
episode is going to show a little just a
little piece of what our life and it's
gonna open up a lot of people's eyes to
know that hey Jim wasn't Lima people who
know us and no one's for years yeah oh
that like this episode is gonna bring a
lot of stuff out into the open however
sugar bear denies abuse allegations
telling et quote it is not true any of
it Jun won't let me see or talk to Alana
hey can you come bring a lot of me and
he knows when his seal that I would not
say no guys on talk or see each other
anything he caused me any free one no so
if there's a blue mood I thought he's
gonna call me as for claims he hurt her
children sugar bear adds Jun is saying
these things because she's pissed at me
I never hurt any kid
[Music]